what's up guys
bang bang it is lunch money time
on a tuesday while while she's trying to
get rich dresses trying to get our lunch
money right i'm here with paulina we got
all black on in uniform ready to rock
and roll ready to rock
and do not forget that block five is now
the sponsor of lunch money which means
you can go to blockbuy.com that is
blockify.com
and you can get an interest bearing
account that earns up to 8.6
apy you can deposit crypto and take out
a us dollar loan
or you can buy and sell crypto on their
crypto exchange where there are no fees
just spread so go to blackfy.com
episode 201 today okay nice
thank you guys for watching yesterday
i'm an investor i sit on the board and
now i
am a very happy user and so will you
that's over we're done with the app just
saying don't
insert the ad in my monologue
harvard yale brown endowments have been
buying bitcoin for at least
a year according to sources to
coindesk some of the largest university
endowment funds in the us have been
quietly buying cryptocurrency for the
past
year or so through accounts held at
coinbase and
other exchanges do you know anything
about this
i think that every endowment is going to
put bitcoin in their investment
portfolio because every investor needs
to put bitcoin in their investment
portfolio
what did you say that one time about
universities or banks
or masquerading uh many of these
are hedge funds masquerading as schools
for sure if you got 40 billion dollars
in your endowment
right by the way that's not a bad thing
that's fine like
guess what you should be able to do
whatever you want rich alumni
yeah that ain't me well that definitely
helps right but also
uh some of the best investors in the
world run these endowments right so so
it's
you gotta just remember that um the
endowments
are there to provide capital
what the problem becomes is if all of a
sudden there's a downturn
and the government is bailing out the
universities yet there's billions and
billions of dollars in the endowment
that's where i'm like eh that feels a
little weird
but the fact that the universities have
this
trading operation uh or this investing
operation that's fine
i think there's a lot of people who take
issue with the fact that they don't pay
taxes
or they don't pay the same taxes as you
would if you just had a normal hedge
fund uh or normal investing shop
but that's a whole other thing whatever
but by the way they're super forward
thinking they were into
uh bitcoin and crypto in what 2018 i
think is when they started allocating
so they've been way way ahead of the
curve here honestly in my head 2018
was last year but it's like three years
ago now wow
um janet yellen has been confirmed by
the senate to become
the 78th u.s secretary of the treasury
what up janet and the first woman
and the first woman treachery
the first the first woman to ever be the
treasury secretary awesome
the newly minted cabinet official hasn't
spoken much on crypto
just yet but during her time leading the
federal reserve board she indicated she
wasn't a huge fan of bitcoin
but called for a light regulation what
can we expect from j
i think that janet yellen is obviously
incredibly smart
um two is she has spent
much of her career as i'll call like a
public servant
meaning that she worked at the federal
reserve uh at various um
you know uh kind of positions there uh
and now it's gonna be the treasury
secretary the federal reserve i think
that she's starting like the mid 90s
so like you know like literally like
20-year run
um and she basically the policy that i
would say is gonna define
her position as the treasury secretary
is that she is willing to
uh constantly use a weaker dollar so to
devalue the dollar
in order to address unemployment she's
stepping into a situation where there's
high levels of unemployment
and therefore my guess is that she is
going to be a big proponent of
continuing to
drop the value of the dollar or devalue
the dollar and to
try to solve that unemployment problem
well when you devalue the dollar that
means that asset prices are going to go
up
and so basically what we're going to see
is a continuation of what we saw for the
last 9 to 12 months
where asset prices exploded the dollar
got weaker
investors won and savers got punished so
under janet yellen it would not surprise
me
all of this continues or and maybe even
accelerates
so janet welcome i'm proud that you are
uh the first woman i think that's
amazing uh
please do not devalue the dollar too
aggressively but because i don't think
you're gonna listen to me
i will be positioning myself to benefit
thank you i think janet is a lunch money
viewer
maybe short sellers are down
91 billion dollars in january as
gamestop leads
squeeze and stocks they all bet against
what has happened to the short sellers
this is my favorite story ever long
story short
is there's a bunch of investors who have
been shorting gamestop it became the
most shorted stock on wall street wow
120 of the shares were sold short which
is literally more than the shares that
exist
uh and then some guys on reddit
who it actually started out as like a
pretty legitimate
investment thesis of hey this stock is
undervalued led by cryptokitten
uh no no led by rory kitty i don't think
rory kitty was actually the first one
coming back
joe kitten i don't know but what we saw
was uh then there started to be a little
bit more
interest uh in wall street beds and some
reddit communities a little bit more
then all of a sudden michael bury from
the big short movie he took a big long
position
wow then all of a sudden the chewy
founder he took a big long position
um and then recently over the last three
or four months the reddit community just
said
screw it let's
oh you just got attacked by the yawn i
give in to them
and and then all of a sudden uh you saw
the reddit community say screw it
we're gonna take it to the man and they
all went long at the same time
and they short squeezed wall street to
the point where literally
melvin capital which is a very well
respected
hedge fund on wall street had it taken
an emergency 2.75
billion dollars from citadel and 0.72
to prevent them from blowing up this is
nuts some dudes on reddit essentially
blew up a hedge fund on wall street
but but but but important here there are
absolutely institutional funds that are
also going long
and helping to exasperate what's
happening so it's not just some guys on
reddit it's definitely other people
they're not saying anything publicly
but they see the chatter they see the
the capital flows and they're also
kind of putting some weight behind it
and so this is
fascinating does this have anything to
do with the company fundamentals or is
this literally just some people on
reddit being like we're
gonna screw the short seller so we're
gonna go in was a combination
because like when when uh ryan the guy
from chewie came in uh i think he took a
board seat and he's like look i'm gonna
turn this thing around like we're
basically going to
make changes to the business so it stops
losing money it starts becoming
profitable we're gonna do this this you
know it's like a whole plan
um and look they might pull it off right
if you can move gamestop from being just
a pure retailer
to let's say maybe they actually turn
them into like esports centers
right and then you also sell things
while you're there there's subscription
there's all this stuff that you can
possibly do but while all of that's
going on you also have the guys on
red uh on wall street bets that are
operating under the name of
roaring kitty and deep effing value and
all this stuff
uh and literally they just short
squeezed them
it went from five bucks like over
seventy dollars it's amazing i don't
like the word squeeze i don't know why
okay ow that's not squeezing that's
messing up my hair um beyond meat
shares soar 31
as the company teams up with pepsico to
make plant-based snacks
and drinks what is a plant-based drink i
don't know
i think like it doesn't have milk
has like almond milk isn't that a
plant-based
i don't know i mean look i get the plant
i get the plant-based meat like sure
whatever that's your thing that's cool
uh but this is good meat alternatives is
it good
well there's still studies show
that we don't know yet but we will find
out soon there is one community that
believes plant-based
is the future uh there is another
community that believes that
that is not healthy uh and there is
another community that believes
that you should eat real meat and not
anything that is uh either
lab-grown or uh kind of this plan based
is different from life of course
yeah of course like lab grown i'm just
saying that there's
there's some people who think that all
all the substitutes for real meat
are not legit but i think it's more
about the like sustainability issues
right cow farts methane
all right anyway the stock is soaring
because of this partnership i think
pepsico
why do we think pepsico is getting into
this it's like the most unhealthy
company i think of frito-lay
frito-lay pepsi what else they have taco
bell don't they have that
hey don't be the attacking taco taco
bell didn't do anything to usually
hey listen if you go and you get some
taco bell
if you're drunk or something
twitter oh by the way guys dominoes and
taco
bell speaking of being drunk anthony and
i put the taco bell on the dominos
anthony and i haven't drank a sip of
alcohol since january 1st it's now
january 26th
oh wow we've done 26 days yeah i'm gonna
see how long i can go
feel good look at look at how shiny my
skin is
you always look that beautiful i'm
waiting for that
oh okay i was probably gonna get in
trouble later today so i just bought
myself
twitter is working on a project called
bird watch
it's a community-based approach to
misinformation
um twitter has launched a pilot version
on its website and the goal is basically
to expand beyond the labels that the
company already applies to controversial
potentially misleading tweets
now people can kind of add notes i think
hold on a second uh users can sign up on
the bird watch site to flag tweets they
find misleading add
context via notes and rate the notes
written by other contributors based on
whether they're helpful or not
this kind of sounds like reddit to me i
don't know like
so if there's gonna be a tweet you're
gonna say that's misleading i'm gonna
add a no
but does that is like kind of like a
thread well it's kind of like
annotations right
annotations but yeah i mean look we'll
see if it works like obviously they're
trying to solve this problem
uh i'm a big believer in that we should
encourage as much experimentation as
possible
what does that mean what if construction
or music
i don't know what's going on that's fine
all right but but hold on
uh do we think that like people i mean
one tweet is you're gonna i feel like
people are gonna use it to be funny
use them i mean possibly but also it
could just be like hey if i tweet
something
you disagree with it you might be able
to go in there and reply or you might be
able to add more context and nuance like
who knows
all right it's ask lunch money time
hashtag asklm
tib asks hey guys massive fan of the
show i'm currently studying chemistry at
university but don't enjoy it anymore
ignore the noise only what are they what
could they possibly
be doing upstairs only finishing the
degree for the doors of opportunity as
i've
invested too much in it to give up oh
the sun
what is it sunk loss fallacy
sun cost um looking to get into private
equity or investment banking as a career
into finance but struggling to get
experience
any help would be appreciated i think
that
uh we now know it doesn't matter what
you actually
uh study you can do anything you want i
wouldn't worry about that
uh and the best way to get experience is
to literally start doing
and so one of the things i would do is
um i would do
investment banking though well one of
the things that would be really
interesting
um would be to basically find a company
break it down
write an investment memo and then send
it to a bunch of
uh the places that you think you might
want a job and introduce yourself and
say hey look
you know i'm a kid in college i think
this is interesting
um i would like to work at your uh you
know company one day
um i'm going to write these i'm going to
try to create one every two weeks
or one a month or whatever i'm going to
uh
put it together and then i'll send it to
you i'd love any feedback you have and
what you'll find is just literally
taking action
uh will be rewarded there's some people
who just like wow that's awesome like i
love it
and then if you actually do high quality
work you'll probably get some pretty
solid feedback
uh and potentially could even get a job
or an internship or whatever
anthony anthony loves to hire people
that he meets on twitter like if they
have
done a quality meme that they sent to
him or
if they've sent him like a clip of like
hey here's how you can improve
lunch money and they literally redid the
video like
it's cool because you can see how
somebody works she's bringing this up
because
uh there is somebody who's helping me
now with uh something that's gonna get
announced tomorrow
on wednesday uh that literally i met
because he kept sending me pretty high
quality high quality memes
like high quality kept referring to him
as my meme guy and i was like you do not
have a meme guy
okay and eventually i was like hey man
like what like who are you
and he told me and i turned out to be an
awesome guy then we got on the phone on
a
zoom call met i'll say hey this kid's
pretty smart
uh and i was like i got some ideas that
i need help working on you want to help
me and he
started helping with a little bit now
he's helping with a lot of bit so yeah
and and
also when we met send me fire memes when
we met
anthony got the job of being my
boyfriend by just
acting like my boyfriend and i was like
i don't need this and he was like hello
[Laughter]
the first day i ever met pelina i
started introducing her as my girl
i was like what the hell is this i don't
know you
i'm kidding okay so joe okay how do you
pronounce last name because i don't want
to mess it up you're italian
i don't think that's italian d free d
free
yeah we'll say super american um
as two creators in the creator economy
what product or service do you wish
existed when you first started out
that still does not exist um
i wish that there was somebody who would
sell ads on my behalf
but like um like
like a boutique ad studio but one person
that i don't i don't have to interact
with advertisers i'd say yes that's a
good idea no i don't like that one
what do you think i don't think i'm a
creator
okay answer the question i'm just saying
what do you
wish that existed more persistence
no yeah like a product or a product
i don't know i'd have to think about it
um i wish i wish there was a way oh i
have a good one
uh i would love to have a way where uh
a video or audio would immediately have
super high quality 100 accuracy uh in
the transcripts oh transcripts for audio
and video that would be
fire yeah but it's super it's very very
difficult problem
kathleen benjamin how much time do you
guys spend preparing for lunch money and
where do you get your
events to discuss so 100 of the
preparation comes from
me zero percent comes from him but he's
already probably read that stuff on
the internet before i bring it my life
is preparation for lunch money
yeah that's true but i typically go to
cnbcnn.com
techcrunch i get a bunch of newsletters
like pitch book 1440
uh the wall street journal and i i scan
through them
and i find these lovely topics for us to
discuss
you go to cnn.com business
yeah it's good it's a good one okay i
don't do any prep
because i just bring my pants i'm like
in a
in a broadcast booth there's the
play-by-play person and then there's the
color commentator i'm the color
commentator
she does the play-by-play i do the fun
stuff
the final question comes from 13 hails
one of my favorite
lunch money commenters uh she asked i
think
she asks my question is for both of you
what are your sources of financial
literacy knowledge other than the
important books like rich dad poor dad
and cash flow quadra et cetera i read
both of those books already and they
changed my life
one of his favorites when did you become
financially literate
are you self-taught or did your family
teach you what are credible sources for
people to gain real financial literacy
now the bs version banks or the
government will sell you for example oh
you're so smart okay for me
um because my parents are immigrants i
grew up with it
a mindset of you gotta save everything
um i was never taught to invest
i was taught to budget which is also
very very important skill
but before i met you really i i i never
i didn't know what investing was i think
i had some money in
um wealthfront i just put a little bit
of money in there and and kept adding
like a hundred dollars a month or every
two months or something like that
um but that's buying an index fund
that's like the s p 500 i think that's
that was good for me but um yeah i think
most people get it from their family
what do you think
and what resources are there so there's
not a lot of good resources that's
part of the issue uh there's some good
books you mentioned a couple of them
like a lot of what robert kiyosaki's
written is great uh i tend to think that
dave ramsey does a pretty good job of
getting people out of debt
um there's this book the dow of capital
that i think is really good
it's a really dense one it's super dense
and and uh
you know may not be applicable to
everybody uh for me i think that the
best thing was just psychologically uh
training or from a philosophical
standpoint uh my parents for my brothers
and i
uh they never gave us allowance and like
all of our friends like people have like
allowances and all this crazy stuff
uh but we never had that and we frankly
we were probably like pissed about it as
kids i don't really remember
um but what i do remember is that
whenever we
were like hey dad you know can i get 20
to go to the movie theater when we're in
like high school or something
he literally would just be like uh go do
this or go do that
like there was this teaching of if you
want money you have to do something for
it
and so i think that one like really
helped us understand like the importance
of
uh working for money um also on top of
that i think my brothers and i
uh each one of us all had like pretty
low level like high school like jobs
like i worked at
quiznos i worked at chick-fil-a um you
know all that kind of stuff and so i
think all of that helps from an from an
income standpoint
and like let's work for money when it
came then to
uh investing and saving like for the
longest time you know my parents
just kept telling us like you know say
just like everybody else um but the one
thing that
um i think became apparent over time was
uh
seeing people uh and hearing from our
parents like hey by the way also like
you should invest right like investing
is how you can grow money
and so i it was enough to put us down
the rabbit hole
and then basically i just spent pretty
much between like 18
and like 24. i just read everything i
possibly could read
about successful people it became
obvious every single person they
basically became wealthy
by doing one of two things they either
invested money or they owned
equity in a company or an asset and so
that just became like obvious like
well all these other smart people do it
then i should do it too one book that
recently came out that i
love um and i think you really enjoyed
it will be helpful
called the psychology of money by morgan
housel
h-o-u-s-e-l it's more mindset but i
think it explains the concepts
really what are you giving morgan free
ads
morgan what's up yeah uh psychology of
money i really liked it
go read it it's a fantastic book uh i've
had them on the podcast i've read the
book
and uh that's actually a really good and
he's an amazing writer
yeah not as good as pulling it but he's
second best he's second he is really
really good
all right guys we'll see you tomorrow
bang bang
hope you guys enjoyed this episode of
lunch money as much as we did
and don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block five
so go check them out there's a link in
the description that you can click on
i'm an investor
a user and a huge fan
what you're a bigger fan of block five
than you are of me
block five is my second favorite thing
in the world behind paulina they've got
three products
they can give you a us dollar loan you
can earn up to 8.6
interest on an interest-bearing account
or you can buy and sell cryptocurrencies
on their crypto exchange
i personally use the interest bearing
account there's not very many places
where you'll find
up to 8.6 interest on a deposit in an
interest bearing account
go do your own research there's risk
associated but 8.6
is pretty compelling so click on the
link in the description say thanks to
the folks at blockfly
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoy pulling in the comments
and we'll see you guys tomorrow and be
kind to your friends